taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds hey taste
buddies welcome to t-a-s-t-e
[Music]
oh my god
[Laughter]
wow i heard the just the concern in your
voice was
was very very charming
steer the ship while i get a towel
all right everybody uh welcome to taste
buddies hey taste buddies welcome to
taste buds he's your host joe derosa i'm
his counterpart sal volcano he just
dropped uh some water on my carpet
and
i mean that's fine joe it's just water
well don't leave it on the floor
it is the towel for the restroom
i figured you'd wash it after this let
it soak up the water
and then you throw it's just spring
water on a clean carpet and then you
wash this and just put a new towel in
your restroom you think i gotta get a
whole new towel now after that
it should you should let it soak for a
minute let it stop up the water a bit
mm-hmm and then you put a new talent all
right well coming at you hot this
episode yeah the uh
lightning app
the chat backfire
i would love to can you go okay in the
edit not to give you extra work if it's
too much too much but can you do like
like just a tr like just keep cutting
back to him going oh my god and then
like zoom in do it a little slower and
then and we can end with an uh
butts
oh my god
all right great just i just i just love
the uh the amount of concern just coming
out of you it scared the [ __ ] out of me
when something spills i get really
scared i dropped my key i dropped my car
key under the seat today on my way here
i stopped to get something to eat
and i that's the worst and i dropped you
gotta get out of the car and like park
and get on your knees and get under the
seat and i went and i went when i
dropped away i went no no no
[Music]
good i want to see it act out
first of all already sad because i'm
going into top tomato
to buy lunch loose luxury to eat because
i'm just like i got to eat something
before i get over there
no
no it was it right in front of you you
picked it right back up no do you go to
pick it up it drops out of your fingers
again and goes underwater it went full
crack and then i went in i went under
the seat and i couldn't see it because
it went under the hole in the rug oh and
i almost lost it i almost fully lost it
wow which i don't know what i would have
done right if it slid like two more
inches i could would have been able to
grab it would have been inaccessible
yeah exactly wow in xs great band
instead suicide block wait is that what
that name means in excess
in excess that's what that means that's
what i always thought it meant
did i not know that till right now i
understand what you're saying because i
don't always think of it when i say it
but
i have had this thought wow i can't
remember did you think inx and s was an
acronym
i just it was the 80s you know i thought
it was just like kind of a cool yeah
yeah
name but uh pimp you know in excess i
know yeah one of my ex-girlfriends love
them okay um all right so we got
lightning rounds this episode we got
three rounds three battles
eight-minute rounds is what i was about
to say to you when we started i don't
hear any [ __ ] when it that
clock hits eight minutes that's it okay
that's it
that's but we're gonna jump into it
right now because then the pod is gonna
be 24 minutes no no i'm just telling you
i'm just because last time we did this
no but i don't agree with those rules
there you're rules that you made up no
because i think that like what if we
don't get to talk enough about that's
the point you've
that's the whole point
that's what it is that's why it's a
lightning round all right all right all
right all right well i think we're gonna
spend a little extra time on one like
this
no
eight minutes that's it so he comes up
to me so you guys know the lighting
round we've had one before it did very
well in the numbers you guys liked it a
lot it's battles that we really like
that we don't think could sustain a full
episode so we crunch in three battles in
one episode all three count as
individual wins and losses in those
columns so it is a weighted episode you
can come in with a big swing and change
the course of the standing record
because you could potentially go 3-0 and
make up huge ground or vice versa right
uh you know or take a nosedive i think
the last time i was one and two maybe on
the lightning yeah yeah i i don't think
the odds are in my favor today
all right well let's start it off we're
doing boxers and briefs which you
brought up and i said uh i mean i guess
i don't know if we could i said i love i
love it it's it's they're always
mentioned together so it is a good
match-up but it's well it's sustained so
we put in a lightning and and you said
to me what are you gonna take you go
briefs and i go boxer briefs you said no
briefs yeah briefs i said what do you
mean and you said i wear tighties
so wait that's all right so let's not
get too into it the boxer briefs yeah he
calls them tities boxer briefs awesome
eyewear they're defined as for people
with penises
wearing tight underwear can push the
scrotum against the body causing the
testes to rise in temperature that's why
it's healthy to wear boxers yeah that's
the age-old thing but is it is it true
who knows anyway boxers were suggested
suggested to us by a fan or two and then
when i went in to add it to the dock we
already had it in the dock oh yeah oh
yeah it's been in there a while so it's
been in there and then also some fans
suggested so that's good yeah then we
have gum versus mint yeah yeah
i'm gum i will be taking mint on that
one i i appreciate gum but mint is the
way to go for me
i kind of wish i would have taken mint
but
are you serious a little bit why
i'm just you're saying that now if
you're a fighter walking into the
octagon of the ring and you're already
psyching yourself out
i don't know if you have a chance two
matches away i got another match for you
first you chose i let you choose i know
i know
yeah no i'm happy i took um i'm happy i
took um all right i forgot why i think
gum's gonna win but i'll take gum i feel
like mint i don't know it's it's we look
a thing we come across in the show all
the time
is
and we always come back to it it's like
we feel like half the audience will vote
for something because they're a younger
demographic
and the other half will vote for
something because they're an older
demographic so i feel like gum
mint is a perfect example of the younger
crowd voting gum and the older crowd
voting mint
it's a tough one it's a real tough one
did you ever use the word mint for slang
was that that was us right regional like
that's mint yeah yeah probably yeah you
must have it was it was all the rage
when we were younger yeah
jerry it was like right after dope
yeah cherry
that's cherry man never heard that in my
life that was more 70s i think cherry
you never heard somebody say that boss
no they'll go they'll go man that car is
cherry yeah you never heard that no yeah
that was like a that was like that was
like
two just four before dope wow cherry no
fat
all that bag of chips
you know
that's 90s though babe
yeah i know i'm just saying all that in
the bag i'm just saying uh and then
we're gonna finish it off with nsync
versus new kids on the block yeah and
it's so funny to compare that too
because you're like older and younger
obviously older people will know new
kids on the block but
even in sync now is they haven't
performed in 15 years or something like
that right so right like younger but
younger kids now probably still know in
sync because of jt yeah yeah top uh top
boy bands really that's what it is you
got you got you know the boy band that
really started it all was new edition
um but i i never considered new addition
to boy band i always consider them just
a group the way you would like the
jackson five or something even though
they were younger i feel like boy band
in the concept of it
is like new kids was because it's like a
part of it is it was assembled you know
what i mean like like new kids um
would menudo have been a boy band
yeah oh yeah
so i guess minuto then was first yeah
well they still exist they're rotating
they just rotate members
menudo the entity stays the same did you
not know that i did know that okay i did
know that you guys on the blockchain
kids on the block were friends i thought
new kids on the block were friends
though
oh yeah they are all from boston
i don't know i just never heard the term
boy band until new kids on the block
yeah yeah i think they're the
quintessential boy band
you know they started all over in sync
certainly hugh and let me let me let me
tell you i've seen new kids on the block
in concert i have not seen in syncing
concert well
i've seen joey fatone sing i have no
clue who i thought i did not even know
they were white
yes nkotb you ever hear that stylized
they were the
instincts backstreet boys slash
you know they were of of of i guess what
the late late 80s
very early 90s yeah yeah i want to say
they they were dominating in like 88.
just 20.
they're still out there these guys god
love them god love them god bless him
who's the oldest jonathan
john and there was john and jordan
knight there was joey mcintyre there was
um
of course donnie wahlberg and then um by
the main man what was his name
vincent no i wasn't vincent carmine
now
dominic
i'm joking i know these there's nothing
no i know i'm just trying i'm just danny
wood danny wood
yes
donnie and danny where do you want to
where do you want to go with this
lightning where do you want to start
where do you want to do
an order okay start with boxers and
brief okay all right babe but there was
something else we were going to talk
about at the top of the show today
oh you were just i forgot to talk about
last episode
did you see this thing i saw it because
you texted it but i i don't my brain
doesn't even compute
i don't understand what's going on
there's an oreo
taco
uh i guess it's coming to taco bell
but i don't understand it's like
wow okay it's not coming to talk about
they dis talk about destorio they said
oreo leaf tacos to us
wow nice move taco bell i like that fine
oh my god
what just happened you sure that's not
old that's from eight years ago
that's from eight years ago him just
brought up oreo and taco bell taco wait
a second oreo tacos from eight years ago
i guess so no no no no that was like now
wasn't it yeah because i don't think
there's gonna be a taco shell for made
of oreos with chopped with meat in it
you could pull up the texture you sent
me i i was like
taco healthy junk food what is that i
mean at that point you might as well
just serve diarrhea wrapped in the wax
paper yeah i mean this this makes sense
this ice cream version of it oh i love
an oreo taco a choco taco oreo i never
had one it looks delish that looks that
looks homemade i don't think that's uh
oreo tacos are the hybrid dessert of our
dreams all right that looks
so good but how do you get that oreo
taco shell look at that how do you get
that
ah
you can't that doesn't they don't just
sell i think that might be a
store-bought oreo taco that somebody
whipped like souped up a bit yeah i
think what i think is that that
bakery or something does it the whole
thing okay i don't think somebody
piecemealed it all right all right
well folks
i'd love to sit here and talk all day
about oreos i know
i'm a little bit delirious we got work
to do yeah we do
let's get into it there it is
breaking news new oreo locos tacos
that's not real joe joe
i didn't send it pips
i was high sorry
i'm like it's in the it's in a package
like you would take out chopped meat
lettuce tomato and sour cream and pull
it out of an oreo sleeve
once in a while pimple said you
something like this that's so funny
because i didn't do anything of it i
looked and i was like no way and you're
right back and you go pip what is going
on here and then pippa will usually
respond with sorry guys been driving for
18 hours
three crying faces
the only person i know that logs more
hours than a trucker and is not a
trucker
um all right folks let's get ready pimp
set that clock for eight minutes
we got boxers versus briefs go
okay
i just want to start over the fact that
you told me downstairs that you were
tighties and i can't stop thinking about
it now you you choose to wear tighties
you choose to wear them
look at that well don't do it dude don't
do that stop who cares like they don't
know like they think i'm an adonis under
this shirt
wow so they're not whities which is
funny because you call them tighties you
gotta call them tidy whitey's they
didn't call it they're they're a dark
blue jockey but they are a full-on brief
i wear a in fact they're jockey brand
and i wear full-on jockey briefs why
support support i hate boxers they ride
up they give you no support and boxer
briefs are even worse because that [ __ ]
rides up your leg the whole time and it
drives me crazy a nice
boxer or i'm sorry a nice brief i don't
wear bikini briefs but a nice brief a
nice low-rise brief by the way high-rise
brief is kind of strange
but a low-rise brief it gives you
support it keeps everything out of the
way your legs are free inside your pants
it's very nice what i mean my legs are
not not free with boxes
i mean i don't know how you can stand it
they drive me crazy i i mean as a child
i wore tighty whities but as soon as i
was no longer a child
i moved away you are in a very i
guarantee you you're in a very low
percentage of people uh of adults that
wear tighty white i am i went through a
boxer thing when i was in high school
and all that stuff but when they did the
seinfeld episode where kramer has to
stop wearing the briefs
and and because of the sperm count thing
and he's going crazy about how much he
hates the butt like i've never related
more to a sitcom you know i
i just think that you're not buying the
quality products in the in the field of
box or a box of briefs i've been trying
tommy john boxer briefs
and they are the most comfortable
underwear i've ever had on in my life
yeah but they they feel the thing rides
up your leg it doesn't ride up though
when you sit when you sit and you move
around
they can stretch and some of them don't
do well at that but there are some of
them that have they fixed that
there's some of them and if you get the
longer boxer briefs that go tight they
definitely don't ride up and then you
just feel like you have a bunch of
excess extra support even on your thighs
yeah i don't like the thing but mine
right now i have one box of briefs and
they stop like right here it's like a
trunk almost like a boxer brief ticket
like a you know what i mean it's like
midway through my thigh they they grip
the leg and they stay in place i have a
pair of those also that's a very sh i
wouldn't even consider that a box or
brief i would consider that an extended
brief
a boxer brief goes you know you know how
they are they go down the thigh yeah
that's there's also that's also like
expanded that's all the way down yeah i
just split the difference with me but
all i'm saying is i but we're talking
boxers versus brief but also i like but
even the boxer briefs they have this
like uh
pouch
so that
you're not
so then crushed up or anything like that
so let's just say let's just say i'll
allow you to include boxer briefs in
your boxers argument
oh yeah no no i won't even do that i'm
just doing boxes you're right
i don't mind boxes at all i thought that
when i switched to boxes i wouldn't like
the
not the lack of support
but
i don't i never longed for it i didn't
miss the support
to me have one purpose
and that's to do
a sketch where a judge stands up and he
has no pants on
and he's got polka dot boxer shorts on
outside of that i think they are
worthless
see i actually
reversing for me a boxer short and i i
don't really wear boxes anymore but i
did for
20 years um a boxer short feels very
comfortable to me and in the few
instances where like i think one time
like i was on a set and i got wet and
they had to change and so they gave me
clothes and i put on briefs but i don't
normally wear them and it had been a
while and i was like oh it's such a
peculiar feeling like in one instance it
yeah i guess it feels like it's
like everything's like kind of tight
like a little bit more like obviously
the opposite of boxes that are
completely off of your body but it felt
weird i felt like some weird wrestler or
a superhero
and and i also felt like odd to be a man
standing in tighty whities because i had
removed them from my life for so long
something about heidi whities is not
fair though i don't wear tighty whities
i wear briefs yeah every pair of my
underwear is colored yeah yeah all right
you're right so it's not white but it's
still the exact shape of a tiny white no
because tiny whities also too
the funniest name teddy wedding is like
uh hanes like it's just not i don't know
i don't know whoa nearly six out of ten
women and more than four out of ten men
said they preferred tidy whities over
other popular types of underwear
including boxer briefs boxer shorts long
johns and jock straps i mean long johns
what are we even talking about yeah
unless you're working outside in the
winter time it's like long johns i don't
even see the point no nobody wears those
those were undergarments back in the day
though where are we at time watch pimp
on the lightning round five two ooh see
it's plenty of time you don't feel like
a little bit of a silly goose when
you're traipsing around your apartment
alone in you
feel like an [ __ ] oh you do
absolutely it's just me by myself what
do i care okay sometimes i will have a
lady over and i will get up and walk
around my my diapers no you won't it
does
no you won't it doesn't show up oh that
is so
weird dude
that's like a child walking around
and especially if you still have your
t-shirt on if you have on a t-shirt and
a tiny one like i usually do oh my god
dude that's literally the uniform of
children four through eight years old
you walk around with tiny whities on a
t-shirt with a girl that you would just
like that you're seeing i dated this
girl they don't mind
they probably do i don't know do you
think how many of those girls they're
revved up from literally made a call or
a text or i had a story i thought it was
like listen i stayed at his house he's
walking around and a t-shirt and tidy
why'd he say
like like the goddamned animals
like what are those called what are
those called the the what were they
called when we were younger
that's so funny dude
are you shooting
oh i'm getting you on the roof for
christmas i usually do
i this i dated this girl katie
no you didn't did she and she would make
fun of me that i wore uh briefs sure and
i would get out of bed she would hate
that she would get so mad at me i'd get
out of bed adjust my briefs nothing else
and i'd be like
i would dance around that's another room
like a little show girl and i go
and she would go stop it she would
scream at me
she's so emasculating
i will say briefs on a woman because i
just like are are can be very very good
huh like when a woman puts on like a
pair of briefs like you see the superman
ones that were red but like the gold
lines what what else would a woman wear
besides briefs well they're not wearing
their their own type of underwear
that's briefs no but like a male brief
i've seen on a woman you know what i
mean like in a way like a traditional
male briefing a woman it works boy
shorts where they work shorts too which
is like their version of boxer briefs
kind of
um it's like the little so you feel more
uncomfortable
and more awkward in boxer shorts than in
your white in your tighties
brother i have bright red
i'll wear them any day over the week of
the over boxers i had a traumatic
experience you can't arrest me you you
couldn't you could break red tidies can
i just tell you this will not tell you
the argument but it's a fun story one of
the last
one last time i remember even wearing
briefs i was in grammar school and i'll
never forget i was at the park we were
playing basketball and so what happened
was back then all my briefs were white
that's just like the standard issue
hanes
for the loom stuff and my mom jacked up
a pair of my whites because she put it
in with non-whites and it washed with a
purple or a red shirt and the net net on
the whitey was that it came out like
this
violet light violet like pastel purplish
pink
and i was like i can never wear these
but i only had a limited amount of
briefs and i wasn't allowed to throw
them away and so i put them off every
time i could and i would wear them dead
last when i had nothing left and i
always felt really weird to wear them
because i'm a kid and i just felt like
hot like light light pink purple
underwear just
i wasn't
confident enough to feel like i could
wear those i don't know it just felt
weird well yeah
okay good news yeah so
as a kid yeah that's it that's a whole
new ball yeah like a pink underwear
right whatever
so
so i i remember one day i had to put
them on i even remember what i was
wearing i was wearing a full matching
duke university
shorts and and t-shirt that i got i
don't know i was like i loved it
we're at the park and someone brings out
a
step step stool and so we're all dunking
on this 10 foot hoop but i'm like 10 you
know like whatever 12 whatever
and i go to dunk
and i'm holding on to the rim hanging
off there and a friend of mine pantsed
me
i'm hanging on the ring rim ten feet i
had to put the light purple pink ones on
yeah
and they they pantsed me and everybody
you might it looked like the like a deaf
comedy gym audience everybody was saying
oh my god
i also was like nervous to just let go
and drop the ten feet but like i had to
that's why
that's a great scene for a movie and i
put my pants back on and i think i've
never worn a tighty again that's a great
scene for a movie yeah that's like a
great wonder years scene it was that's
what it was like yeah wow that's amazing
have you been pants derosa oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh it used to be a thing i
don't think that's salt right yeah i
don't see people doing that nowadays but
it wasn't back in the day i mean my
dad's so old school he's like oh we used
to do that with tube tops i'm like jesus
yeah that's crazy
just like up and then yeah that's why
and then they just
pull it back that's why it is if you
think about what panting was which was
by the way i don't know if it was just
an age bracket thing i don't know if it
was a regional thing but
when panting was in
you could get pants at any moment of any
day
for like for like
years i used to do weird things i used
to tie that [ __ ] cause and you and it
was your fault if you got pantsed and
you they didn't stay up that was your
fault we used to do a thing we used to
do a thing in college
in the dorm
where you could you could never do this
now where my buddy and i would set it up
he'd have like a bunch of the guys from
the from the dorm hallway in his room
and he wouldn't he knew i was going to
do this so like i'd set it up with him
i would go to the and they didn't the
guys in the room didn't know we were
going to do this i would go to the door
and knock
and i'd have my pants down
and uh and uh full out dick out and
everything and uh and then my buddy
would answer the he would go who is it
and then he would open the door and go
look everybody it's joe and his prick
and i would come dancing in waving my
dick around and everybody would just
laugh and thought it was funny one guy
got disgusted and would leave every time
we did it
and then by the end of the semester he
thought it was funny and he would hang
out for him yeah but i mean can you ima
if i did that now i'd be in jail
even to guys
it was just guys there were no girls in
the room to be clear too i i don't think
i i don't i probably have pants someone
back but i've never pantsed a woman no
no or a girl at that when i was in
college i i like you we knew it was all
guys
i never saw a girl get paid you knew
well enough that it was that it was
wrong to pants a woman but i st that
being said i don't think it was defined
yet as assault still you just knew like
i shouldn't do that
i mean everyone was watching american
pie back then and thought anything was
on the table right right and i tell you
this it's never a good time to get
pantsed
there's never a good time every time is
the worst possible time
all of a sudden you're there and then
you have no more pants
you know
i really got into denim at that time
heavy into the dungaree
all right let's go to the next debate
okay uh what do we got converse men
speaking of pants
something you keep in your pants your
gums or your mints
which keeps which is the better breath
freshener
well no that's not true
hey taste buddies want to talk to you
about light stream
live stream are your credit card bills
keeping you up at night interest rates
in double digits i'm constantly worrying
about money i've been there many times
rates money i always feel like do i have
enough to to to retire on to live to
support my family do i have this do i
have that i'm always worrying i uh i've
been down the credit card road many
times and i've been down the debt road
many times and i have a feeling it's not
my last rodeo
so joey rose's opening halloween weekend
we have uh i i this is we're we're happy
to bring this uh service to your
attention yeah be smart and pay off your
credit card balances with a credit card
consolidation loan from livestream rates
start at 4.98 that's pretty damn low
with auto pay and excellent credit plus
the rates fixed it'll never go up over
the life of the loan you can get loans
from five to a hundred thousand dollars
uh just for our listeners apply now to
get a special interest rate discount and
save even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to livestream.com
taste buds that's l-i-g-h-t
s-t-r-e-a-m light stream
tastebuds so you want to hit that ending
subject to credit approval rates range
from 4.98 apr to 19.99
apr and include a point
five zero percent auto pay discount
lowest rates require excellent credit
terms and conditions apply and offers
are subject to change without notice
visit lightstream.com tastebuds for more
information we gotta tell them about
durham october 29th
durham performing arts center dorm is in
north carolina north carolina's in the
united states yes we will be there
co-headlining just like we did in
baltimore ask the people at the lyric
theater how much they love that show we
co-headline we do some stand-up and then
we come in at the end we take some
questions from the crowd you gotta be
there during performing arts center
october 29th fitbot fitbot fitbit fit
bod
let's talk about exercise and i gotta
tell you something my favorite
thing about exercise is versatility my
least favorite thing about exercise is
repetition because you keep doing the
same thing over and over it kills your
progress it kills your motivation and
next thing you know you're not doing it
anymore so perfection you know this this
practice makes perfect that's an
illusion all right there's always a
higher level to strive for that looks
different for everyone especially when
it comes to fitness and this over here
is perfect there's no perfect body that
anyone can achieve we all know that but
we can continually become better
versions of ourselves
okay
uh i like the app because the workouts
get tailored to uh my needs right uh you
don't necessarily uh you know or the
equipment i have i should say you can
look on the app and match the equipment
to what they have so they'll give you
workouts for what you have access to and
what i what i say too often when we talk
about fitbot is that you know i was
somebody that would go on youtube and
sort of try to make these playlists of
different workouts and things and
whatever the problem i would have is
after a while you'd run out of the
videos
and you'd be watching the same things
over and over i like that fitbot is
constantly evolving they are they're
keeping the videos fresh the routines
don't get boring or old uh
and
every muscle group that's important too
because a lot of times i i'm not one i'm
not a gym rat myself and i don't really
know when i'm hitting i i need some
education in the gym you see those
videos of people in the gym and they're
just using a machine completely the
wrong way they're just like hanging on
to a rope and going back up and down
that's me um yeah yeah you get like
pulled up
yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh pick up the pace on
your fitness journey with this fit pod
today the it's an app if we didn't
mention that and your future self will
thank you get twenty five percent off
your membership at fitbo dot me
slash taste buds that's twenty five
percent off at fitbot dot me slash taste
buds this is the time to do it too babe
we're heading into winter you don't want
to wait till it gets warm again and then
you got to go out you do you put in the
work in the winter everybody knows that
yeah
and by the way for anybody thinking
why would i listen to these two about
we're exactly the kind of guys you need
to listen to about fitbot because we're
exactly the kind of guys that need this
sort of thing this is for somebody who's
not a gym rat not a fitness nut that
wants to stay in shape fitbot or if you
are and you don't want to go to the gym
you just want to be a home run that too
all right
wait let's make her let's just go all
right which is the better breath or
upper go
i mean it's not even necessarily a bro i
mean mint is usually exclusively a
breath or upper gum not always because
you got you know fruit flavors and
garlic which to me is why gum wipes the
floor with mince that's why i said
earlier oh i forgot why i picked gum
it's because gum
i mean dude there are there are stores
dedicated to gum you know they're
they're they're or that's not true
you look he's getting better he's
getting he's rehabbing there are
sections of candy stores dedicated to
gum and mints well if you're going to
try if there's a gum isn't it but if you
go into it that's not true if you're
going to a tried and true candy store
like a place like like there's one in my
neighborhood i forget what it's called
we're reaching fun but no no we're not
we're no we're not there they're candy
stores out there if you go to a tried
and true candy store or like rocket fizz
is one of those places it's a small
chain that sells soda and candy but it's
all novelty stuff they have like a gum
section and it's like
it's like a tribute to all your favorite
gums they've got bazooka they've got a
double bubble they've got bubblicious
and i like that you mentioned this and
they won't put like the dentines in
those in there okay it's all the fun
gums i understand that and i and i will
say i'm glad you mentioned that because
i loved gum like any other person you
know on the on the planet but then i got
a little older
then i turned you know 17
and then gum wasn't really in my purview
anymore and i'll tell you right now gum
right now it's out in no man's land for
me because i don't i'm not buying a big
leaked shoe now i'm not buying a hubba
bubba or a bubblicious now i don't want
that kind of like
purple chewing gum like that i don't i
don't think you take a pack of that
stuff on an airplane it'll change the
whole flight it's delightful
it's delightful it's too much it's too
sugary it's too synthetic it's too cheap
and another thing i don't like about gum
is i hate when gum i even right now it's
making me it's like nails on a
chalkboard but i hate
when gum loses it's all of its
like flavor and then it's like almost
like a squeaky
you know when it gets like it loses all
the sugar and it's almost like you're
chewing like and that's that like when
you're supposed to spit it out i i'm
just thinking about it
just thinking about it you get off an
airplane you get off something about
your
teeth
chomping onto a gum and it's like
squeaky and like you get off an airplane
after an airplane sleep when you've got
that sleepy mouth
mint
now dude i popped two dentines one two
in each side you need terrible you need
to because they're too small and i walk
and i chew it on both sides and it's i
feel like it's like a car wash for your
mouth all right that's what the mint is
designed to do okay and then i don't
feel it
you ever have to check out now where the
impulse buys are the mints they have now
are just next level mints i love a good
mint show me a modern mint i haven't
seen enough yeah
i'm not gonna educate you right certain
tic tacs are the old school i don't even
know if they still sell certs i don't
know if they looking at here you're
talking about the uh uh i see creative
landscapes
let's not even get to there's so many
goddamn mints that's not worth talking
about there are so many myths i'm not
gonna educate you on mints but honestly
i used to love certs and and tic tac
shout out search
savers i'm seeing tic tacs i'm seeing
altoids these standards what what what
what innovations are we making i'm
telling you dude i got so many
downstairs every single gum
every single gum except like
every gum has a mint they all have it
every brand has their own dentine has
mints
there's so many mints dude here's what i
don't like i don't like when it loses
its flavor i don't like when it gets
stiff and hard as a rock some mints have
their gums
tic tacs had gum for a little while god
bless yeah all right i'm just saying gum
i think it's for a younger person even
now you talk about like the the juicy
fruit the uh the spearmint the the that
kind of thing the
big red i don't like that gum either
that quarter gum that 35 cent gum that
has five sticks in it you put it in your
mouth it's good for
i swear it's good for two and a half
minutes
it's good for two and a half minutes oh
juicy fruit is the worst offender don't
you juice the worst yeah yeah wrigley's
greatly spearmint and then the white one
the green one and then you got your big
round oh juicy fruit juice juice fruit
nothing like putting a stick of juicy
fruit in your mouth the stick hits your
tongue the gum full like the commercial
yeah but it does but it does what flavor
is juicy fruit it does it's juicy fruit
juicy fruit loses its flavor
immediately i'll tell you this
immediately you bite you get like maybe
like a couple of mouthfuls of juice and
then all of a sudden that thing is
dry squeaky hardening and you got to
spit it out and put it in the foil i'll
tell you this 35 cents is too much for
that guy i'll tell you this you're nuts
i'll tell you this about mints i'll tell
you this but they're overpriced number
one number one they're way overpriced
number two choking hazard
every time
what do you put the mic down for choking
house choking hazards
it's a hard thing in your mouth the
whole time
you know what i like to do i mean i like
to take a minute and put it right here
like i'm packing a skull or like a thing
it's a choker and it stays because i
don't i'm not biting it and swirling it
around it stays right here for a good
hour it's a choking hazard it's like
time releasing your mix it's just
choking out so you have fresh breath for
a full teeth break do it every day pimp
it's a teeth it's a teeth
people break their teeth on mint
sometimes joe you are flailing right no
i'm not no i'm not i just and also also
and also
it is
uh arrogant
oh
stop attaching this like arrogance
hold on who's the most american person
on planet earth jerry lewis what is the
impression of jerry lewis always with
the lozenge or the mint
every time somebody you're a lunatic you
do it you do an aggregate person there
you go you go
oh you're sucking all that
gum you're walking around chewing like a
cow it's just like chewing on gum like a
cow i mean we're reaching here all i'm
saying is gum was popular with me when i
was a child as i get older i want a mint
i'm an adult i suck on a mint i use my
mint for fresh breath for a little treat
little wake me up i i i just think
mints are delicious
gum for me i just think it's weak i
think it's weak ass i think it loses its
flavor i think it's for children i don't
think they make that good of gum i don't
like all the sweet grape orange sherbet
watermelon i'm not down with that [ __ ]
anymore bazooka classic gum
but let's let's give me a break i mean
it it it's hard as a rock and it loses
its flavor immediately
on the downside mints usually dissolve
quickly so you're likely to consume them
at a faster rate i would agree to that
higher sugar intake
chewing gum helps remove food particles
and bacteria from your teeth
stimulates saliva production wells which
can help also with bad breath and dry
well that's a mint does that end then
things here getting no food that's just
gross is it not oh man i got some extra
spinach and chicken in there let me see
pop a piece of gum in my mouth
i will catch the spinach
and the chicken in my watermelon gum
it's at particles and then i will and
then by the way once it gets in there
that's like silly putty
you're chewing chicken and spinach
inside your bowl of gum it said
particles
not least
i don't want food particles in my gum oh
please what do you think so you'd rather
just them stay in your teeth as you eat
your mint
that's gross no i'll brush i'll brush
too but it's saying if you want to get
the job done on the run the gum's going
to get it done
ah i don't like that i'm getting juicy
you put gum in the car or something and
then you don't have a while it gets
still you put gum in your pocket oh you
know what i hate would come to gum in
your pocket
it starts to melt you open it up all the
gum and the wrappers are like flattened
you see pieces of gum jutting out the
sides of the foil it gets all sticky
you open it and then the gum is stuck to
the foil
i remember what i was going to talk
about it wasn't the taco i just
remembered what it was
sal
wanted me
invited me and jay okerson to go to
can i talk about this sure yeah it wants
us to go march in the halloween parade
we're going on halloween night who's we
me and chris
it's all happening
it's all happening you not like the
parade it's fun
i'm not i just told them about it they
were overjoyed i made fun of overjoyed
wait you're going with him you mean well
i mean i was going to photograph the
parade i'll hang out for a bit yeah the
uh can chris do anything without
videotaping it anymore is it possible
jesus christ
[Laughter]
so wait you're going to shoot a bit with
chris are you going i i like to
photograph that period you're going just
to photograph the parade period yeah
look i got nowhere to go so i'll be
there unless it's we the week of my bar
you're gonna sound like an old guy also
too it'd be nice if the week in my
borrow and maybe my friends instead of
going to a
20 thing that happens every year maybe
they come to their best friend's grand
opening i don't think i would open on a
holiday weekend huh
what are you going to open on a holiday
weekend
we keep 29th i'm in durham performing
31st is the actual parade yeah so the
only day we would have free there is the
30th right but i'm saying if we were to
open on the halloween weekend you're
telling me you on halloween night
instead of coming to my joey rose's
halloween event you would go to the
halloween parade million percent really
yes really i don't want to miss joey
rose's opening for the life of me but i
will be there the other 364 days if i
like halloween comes once a year the
parade was cancelled last year it's one
of the things i look forward to the most
and i haven't done it in well i haven't
done it in probably eight nine years
this is the greater
so you must not love it that much well
it wasn't last time yeah no i haven't
done it in about 100 in nine years yet
you need to do it i used to the night of
your best friend's borrowed i used to do
it with uh the with the patrons of the
book it means so much to you what kept
you away from it last year
a sale at walmart no actually a global
pandemic
the uh
little different jesus i love this i
can't come to the grand opening of your
bar because i have to go how about don't
grand open your bar on a national
holiday
what in a mate are you if i can i'm
trying to that can you imagine a more
amazing time you don't you don't you
don't read anything i write you don't
listen to me and you don't think right
because i told you that the parade
started at seven and you could do the
whole thing in about two hours and you'd
be done by nine right and then you can
go to any bar you want i said that did
you come after me of course i would all
right great i think i'm going to come
now with that freaking attitude yeah
that's right here wait this isn't the
point though we're sidetracking yeah
we're not even definitely opening we're
trying to we're trying to it's just a
matter of principle okay but here's the
thing this is the part i want to tell
you yeah i said on bonfire yesterday as
jay and i made fun of you and r shafir
for wanting to go march in this parade
yeah endlessly for an hour i'll read my
text i'll read them i think they'll sign
with me this is this is the only this is
the part relevant to this show
i said to jay
sal said in i was reading one of sal's
text and i said sal says in his text you
go you get bombed
and i said you know jay it's interesting
that sal wrote that you get bombed
because sal claimed two weeks ago on an
episode of taste buds that he doesn't
like to drink anymore and consumes less
than seven alcoholic beverages a week
true and jay's face
i can only
describe it as when a nun goes to her
superior and says i'm leaving the face
the absolute
disgusted disbelief he was
[Music]
it's not true if you're talking about
when we're on vacation yes and the one
time i got drunk listen there you go
eddie geek said the words he goes i
gotta go hear this i gotta go i gotta go
hear this really yeah no i well by the
way i told you what i used to do with
the patrons from my bar am i when i'm
saying you get bombed i mean the royal
you like everyone in the street is
drinking nobody cares it's a very
feel-good like very like that i get yeah
the focus here but you can just chase
reaction to your claim that you don't
drink
i didn't say i don't i didn't say i
don't
drink less than seven drinks a week i do
and this was discussed on air it was
disgusting
i wish i had the clip i wish i had video
of his face
his face i drank what is what are you
talking about
i'm trying to think about this all right
in the last two weeks i think i drank
one night all right let's not i had a
martini with dinner
uh look
fall
of all the seasons yeah it could be a
hectic oh the the kids go back to school
the holidays are coming the holidays are
coming strong
and they ain't stopping you're gonna be
in there you're gonna be in the uh
supermarket spending all your money and
times to carve you've got turkeys to
stuff you've got candy to hand out
you've got christmas ornaments to hang
you don't have time to cook with
hellofresh you get fresh pre-measured
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered to your door
skip trips to the grocery store counter
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable that's why it is we say
it all time america's number one meal
kit you think you got variety in the
supermarket they have over 50 menu and
market items to choose from ingredients
travel from farm to your door within a
week low prep one pan 10 to 15 minute
meals now i know that counts as cooking
but 10 to 15 minutes you have what you
don't have is go to the store
what cut should i get mr butcher you
don't have time for that you got to get
home you got this isn't 1920s you're not
smoking unfiltered camels and even if
you are this allows you some more time
to smoke some extra unfiltered camels
i'm not one that will like cook a lot
when i'm home alone but like my when my
nieces came and visited me last week
they slept over we picked a meal we
cooked together it was one of the
funnest things we did the whole stay
they had that's great that's great so go
to go to hellofresh.com tastebuds 14 and
use the codes tastebuds 14 for up to 14
free meals including free shipping
that's hellofresh.com
tastebuds14
use the code tastebuds14
get up to 14 free meals with free
shipping
and
hellofresh
and america's number one meal kit i love
honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey we
all shop online we've all seen that
promo code field taunt us at the
checkout thanks to honey manually
searching for the coupon codes is a
thing of the past that's me i see it i
cannot bear to hit check out knowing
that there might be a code floating out
there i go on a hard target wide net
internet search everything comes back
unusable okay when i found out about
honey i literally thought they made this
app for me i installed it on my browser
and on my phone and i finally it paid
dividends did i tell you this i ordered
a bouquet of flowers the other day 30
off not making that up swear to g
uh honey pops up almost you know you get
the little plug-in or the browser
extension rather and it sources the
internet for these promo codes it pops
up every time i'm checking out uh and it
supports over 30 000 stores online so
you have nothing to lose really you know
this is i don't get why you wouldn't do
this it's free yeah and it's peace of
mind you know that you're not losing out
yeah i don't want that fomo yeah so when
you check out this honey button drops
down you click apply coupons you wait a
few seconds and you'll find them if they
got anything that works for the site
it's great
scroll that pimpy for me uh if you don't
have if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free it installs
in a few seconds by getting it you're
doing yourself a salad and supporting
this podcast get honey for free and at
joinhoney.com
taste buds that is join honey dot com
slash taste buds
by the way i got a text from my friend
two days after that podcast posted
he posts a thing online what's he doing
in the story drinking what's he drinking
a margarita
double hypocrite sends me the story he
goes after all his [ __ ]
i'm not going to bulk up this tree again
i i don't know what to tell you i don't
really i'm not trying to open the camera
it's just funny it's so it was so funny
yeah
look at you you're like he's like why
would i want to go to the parade
i'm like it's the biggest halloween
parade in the country about a million
people come to watch it everyone's
partying the vibe is fierce
people
people are watching from this their
terraces their roofs so there's a party
in every apartment going on every single
business is going buck wild the bars are
spilling out again usually i don't like
like that tight quarters and mayhem and
stuff like that but it's it's different
especially because you're allowed to
march in it so then here's and you just
get online and you go and i usually go
with a big group and people are you know
and then there's tons of music street
performers dancers people in costumes
people on stilts there's crazy floats
going by the energy is wild and i'm not
sure it's like no other night and and we
usually will get uh candy bags of candy
so as we march to the parade we throw
candy into the crowd and everyone's
screaming by the way you described it
yesterday you wrote and we throw dead
serious we throw treats out to the crowd
yeah well we don't we don't throw tricks
but you call them treats yeah it's
halloween it was funny it was funny
trick-or-treat but here's the thing
here's the thing i understand do you
understand what jay my perspective on
this is jay and my perspective on this
is after years and years and years of
being down at the comedy cellar on which
is in the heart of where that is
on the night of that parade
it has never been enjoyable it has been
it has been bourbon street times
twenty-five what you're saying
so if you can convince me otherwise
and if we don't open the bar that
weekend i'll be there i shall convince
you i don't really go
off the outskirts into the [ __ ] show but
i'm in the parade man in the parade you
got all of six avenue to yourself you're
just walking there the [ __ ] shows out
there you're throwing treats
and you know you got a little like water
bottle full of nice chilled what
whatever you have well you or you don't
and you're waving and you're
throwing them and you're taking photos
of people and like you know people call
you over if you're in a good costume and
it's just it's a
it's a real new york thing i think it's
the best event in the city every year
yeah and he's never been he's [ __ ]
on it you know
eight nine years i did that parade with
people it was we looked forward to it
every single year we all wore the same
costume that's the i think i'm leaving
out so you're leaving out some stuff the
point is to get into a costume everyone
the same because a lot of people do and
so you know you can find your group
right away and then you're a roving gang
of
you're a roving gang of chickens like we
threw chicken nuggets uh when we were we
were bunnies we threw carrots i hate the
matching costumes you have to be
anonymous i know yeah so your face isn't
covered i never like covering my face at
halloween i'm a i'm a i'm a paint guy or
an eye mask kind of guy
uh what do you owe you a big halloween
you're the guy that comes
you come either your face is done in
pain with some crazy prosthetic that you
tried to pull off something horror or
you're the guy that just comes in like a
striped shirt and like i'm a referee
my big costume for years was i always
went with my staple which uh clark can't
turning into superman there you go
that's lame ass [ __ ]
yes it is and you did it all the time
yeah how unoriginal it's not lame ass
[ __ ] that's your costume every year
part of the fun you get to wear a suit
part of the fun of halloween every year
is is being like what is you have a
blank canvas what am i gonna do this
year
i don't like being uh uh burdened down
by a big costume i don't like if there's
any
if there's anything where what do you
mean a big costume if there's any
struggle to go to the bathroom i'm not
i'm going to be pissed off if there's
anything where i can't just like
freely eat or drink and i'm i'm sweating
because i i run really hot too well we
make sure that i don't like a mask we
make sure that we we try to get stuff we
are not sweating we learned our lessons
and also you always have a hole here for
the food and drink okay
yeah look
as i said you could pull it up for a
second gets around
right now i'll tell you this right now
and i said it on a text dread if i don't
open the bar that weekend i'll be there
why i'm lonely i have nowhere to go
you should just there's nowhere you
should come and shoot you might gonna
sit home alone you should come as you
and your apartment you come in that ice
cube t-shirt with tidy whitey's on and
just
just wave it won't match
well match
the matching part i hate what
the matching costumes i hate well we'll
all go with that then you guys all match
and then i'll know where you all are
don't worry about me you'll be able to
see me because i won't have a mask on
all right last battle this is the big
one one other thing that you like about
this if i may say so i don't think i'm
blowing up your spot you like the
anonymity of it yes because you can be
out in a big crowd of people and go
anonymous and just
right which i get because i've been out
with you many many many times in many
different places and and
you you are very frequently recognized
and i'm and you're always very gracious
but i'm sure it gets tiring
however yeah on the text thread last
night
are you ready for this i'm excited don't
lie because i'll pull it up no i'm not
lying all right no no this is not
against you okay so sal says you know i
get to be an honest fun night for me i
know you're gonna say i know you're
gonna re shafir tells me and jay okerson
to die
because we said we didn't want to go
right
just go die whatever and then he goes
it's a fun night it's a parade it's
drinking it's partying sal gets to be
anonymous i get to be anonymous
this
lunatic
thinks he could possibly need to be
anonymous
[Music]
it was the most insane thing i've ever
seen a human being say
can you believe that
was he joking
i don't know nobody backed me up when i
trashed him about it i scratched him
around the thread yeah of course i did
nobody backed me up
i stick to rosa i love it
all right uh in sync versus knew i was
gonna find i was gonna find it and see
what you said all right so someone said
we doing this halloween parade thing or
not they texted examples of what we
could do don't say anything because i
don't want people to know who we are um
and then
you left a whole
let's let's see hold on
sorry all right uh
you left a voice memo saying that it
sounds terrible jay's like i'm with you
it sounds like a nightmare uh you said
can't we just paint our faces and go get
boozed up in
can we go get cocked on booze and reefer
in the park
jay said i did a parade once my takeaway
super hot and freezing cold long
tiresome and boring with zero reward
convince me convince me otherwise
um
jay and i are about to trash this on the
air when we return from break
we're live on sirius if you want to tune
in
i said it's actually great i organized
it for many years straight it's not if
it's not but if it's not your thing it's
not your thing we just get you know good
and buzzing and we march in the parade
and throw treats at the crowd
also the parade's insane there's crazy
floats and costumes and huge mechanical
things etc a million people watch all
along six there from spring all the way
up you can leave at any point if you did
the whole thing it only takes a couple
hours all the bars are jamming
everyone's drinking outdoors no one
cares etc i just said it a lot i really
like it it's fun mayhem it's fun mayhem
it's the only parade you're allowed to
just flat out join
but i get what you're saying if it's not
for you i even said that i know
we still made fun of you though
we did a bar crawl last year and it was
fun at night so ari's chiming in and you
kept prompting him
ari
are you pro or again because i didn't
understand what he was trying to say and
so i said are you pro or against parade
and then he said parade i was very i
said in my experience i've lucked out
with mild weather most times as long as
it's not raining it's fine and it's just
a wild sight to see and be a part of but
it definitely takes some effort i'll i
said that to you he said his father he
said costumes are fun sal never gets to
be anonymous the weather's usually
beautiful i get to be anonymous booze
that's not a joke
there's a joke around that he's really
saying he gets to be anonymous
oh yeah i forgot it's awful to really
enjoy everything new york has to offer
you idiots which i get that he you know
you don't yeah just the guy that moves
moves to venezuela every winter for nine
months
yeah ari tell us about what new york has
to offer he says go go
go die already because that's what you
that made me laugh yeah it was funny
all right you're supposed to read my
response i love how ari clumped himself
in with salaz quote-unquote needing to
be anonymous
and only christine evans laughed at that
tweet also guys i don't know if you saw
it in the recent episodes of taste buds
but sal no longer likes to drink so this
will be a sober stroll
then then i made a joke about i go hey
gang there's a great bus tour where we
can go see the sights in new york it
even stops at the statue of liberty
let's go enjoy new york
he responds with two more paragraph
texts about how he likes to go on bus
tours
it's a magical city i know i love this
city it's my favorite place
i love going on bus tours i do it every
time i go to a new city because it's the
easiest way it's like 20 bucks it's a
day-long pass you're sitting
on a 15 feet in the air and you're just
chilling you can get off and on however
much you want so recently i was like why
don't i because whenever i go to a new
city i hit the ground running i'm like
tell me where the best museum is tell me
where the best freaking you know
taco places tell me where the best this
is and i go and i hop on the thing and i
always enjoy it you get off at any time
it's good and i'm like they have these
home
i got to start treating new york every
once in a while like i'm here visiting i
don't want to take it for granted
because this has everything everybody
else has and more yeah and i just said i
really i made a pact to myself i told
you recently that i want to start
exploring more of the deeper cuts of
what new york has to offer you know what
i'm going to say it on air i'm going to
say it all right this is for the record
oh no no no no this is for the record
you convinced me i i'd like to do the
parade wow
wow
you convinced me
wow so if we're not opening i'll be
there not out of loneliness i'll be
there okay well i think you're gonna
enjoy yourself i got news for you all
right let's go last battle
battle of the boy bands oh boy no
disrespect to nkotb and no disrespect to
joey fatoneses because i know him a
little bit because you're friends with
him sure yeah he's a very nice man yeah
yeah uh
and uh before i liked fatone though i
would still before i knew fatone i would
still
say that nsync has got to be oh we
forgot about the latest and greatest
band to tackle that was one direction
one direction
[Music]
men
i forgot about boys to men
you wish you could have done
but i don't consider them a boy band
either those are adult men singing r b
there is there is a there is a strange
maturity about new edition and and um
boys did not feel like a boy
they felt like like r b artists they
were felt a little older you know like i
don't know i mean i would describe it as
uh hip-hop r b smoothed out on
bam stick smoothed out on an r b tip
yeah anyway all right
listen by the way i just sang
uh well that was bell biv devoe so and
whose suggestion was it was yours thank
you at the comedy jam killed all right
so all right i want to know um we took
you took new kids you were contemplating
whether you would take backstreet we
didn't think of one direction i don't
know any of one direction i know very
little of backstreet i said new kids
because new kids are when it comes to
boy bands they are the goats yeah well
they are i think we as far as we were
concerned they were the ones that helped
coin the phrase boy band maybe we were
saying yeah the term seemed to be when
it came in prior to them i mean there
was menudo new edition but i don't label
them as the five
guys marketed to the teens and the girls
and that sing all these poppies
i feel like bef we were talking about
earlier on this episode i was saying
that i felt like new edition and menudo
were a lot more similar to like the
jackson five who were young guys but
they weren't it wasn't like real menudo
i think is certainly a boy band but i'm
not sure but but basically
what this is saying is that beatles are
considered the first boy band according
to this
and they stink
so
then come the osmonds okay the monkeys
are considered a boy band i'm a fan of
the monkeys uh i i think that like the
monkeys are good you said i'm a fan of
the monkeys the beatles stan it'll stink
they bug me they bug me i don't know
what to tell you they bug i can't get
over it i agree with you i agree i like
the jackson five boys boy bands
were a lineage from duop which i love do
up
listen here's i'm gonna i'm gonna sum up
my argument in one phrase here's the
thing real quick though i i we we did
wonder cause you did choose new kids on
the block because they have the cachet
of being
really who we believe to be the the
godfathers of the boy band as we know it
today in a way
and uh and so that's uh that those are
heavy hitters and that can in that
regard i don't think the term boy band
existed until then right so my question
to you is though will a lot of our
listeners know well anyone our age is
going to love them um but anyone like
you know like a lot younger might not
really even know we were talking about
this earlier yeah yeah yeah in sync at
least was uh a good what and sync was a
good thing it takes a full a full decade
or more after uh a decade news for you
nsync is 20 years ago i know which is
crazy but i'm going to sum up my
argument
in one phrase as to why new kids are
going to win ready
[Music]
the right stuff
i
i think nsync's got a ton of great stuff
they got nothing that's that were you
talking about the song or the
choreography the choreography
let me tell you something right now i
know what it is without a doubt though
without someone make a good gift for
that without a doubt that was the worst
dancing in choreography i've ever seen
but the point is even even in relation
to what the dance was supposed to be
that's fine but you but here's the point
even when as bad as i sang it and as bad
as i danced it you still knew exactly
what i was talking about there is not a
signature in sync dance and there's not
a signature in sync uh bye-bye is the
biggest signature with boy band dance of
all time what's the dance
bye bye bye bye bye
um
they do people do their dance when they
do karaoke everyone knows the bye bye
bye dance it's as popular as the right
stuff dance you're talking out of your
whole all right
in sync
to date the back oh i wouldn't have
known that at all i would have bet
against that
what to date the backstreet boys
remained the most popular boy band of
all time in terms of sales
one direction also broke numerous
records during their six year run
okay i thought nsync had them
by far
but you didn't take backstreet boys you
took new kids new kids would have been
the all-time greatest selling yeah i
don't know how about this
are you helping him
i know i saw new kids on the blocking
concert i saw them at the mtv concert at
the nassau coliseum and on the bill
headlining with them was paula abdul
millie vanilli and also
new kids have spawned many more actors
than nsync did
joey mcintyre is an actor joey mcintyre
who else donnie walls oh what are we
talking about
yeah all right i've seen fatone oh yeah
god bless pop up in a thing here and
there but timberlake is is is the
full-time actor out of insync they
haven't spawned more you know no you're
just saying stuff
i want to tell you about i am i'm saying
mcintyre and walls are like pretty
steady actor i mean
justin timberlake is an a-list
hands-down emmy nominated a-list actor i
mean he's he's literally as big as it
gets right
but i'm saying two don you got a donny
daddy he works you you throw me at
donnie joe i know joey could
do more acting but but he doesn't does
i went to joey as an actor before donnie
because donnie's in like a lot of shows
i'm saying but no no dude in sync though
is
they they i think they sang better than
everybody else i think they had better
voice and harmonies than everybody else
in this category at least
i mean shout out one direction shout out
back to your boy shout out new kids on
the block god bless
you i don't think anybody home you're
gonna give you're gonna give new
instinct over knew a dish or you're just
saying it's a new addition
because i was young when they came out
and i don't think they were marketed at
the same time
you're saying i love knowing you're
saying from our time period i got you
like late 80s but all i'm telling you is
i think that nsync had the best pipes
the best harmonies i think they had the
best songs i think their songs stand up
more of the test of time they have more
like
dancing backstreet yes but backstreet is
more to me like we're not back we're in
a talking backstreet we're talking about
new kids too new kids doesn't even
they don't even play their songs right
now but dude dude you you
they were still playing new kids 20
years after new kids but right now and
you gotta you gotta you we're we're much
too early on to say if backstreet i mean
if uh nsync has truly stood the test of
time we're still in that 20 fully
disagreement we're still in that tweet
we have like a at least a
kids doing dozen
2022 stadium tour for god's sakes i mean
that's crazy
here's the thing new kids right now
we're removed from new kids by what 30
plus years right
you don't hear their music they probably
stopped in 91 so about 30 years okay so
you don't hear the music on the radio
so
i don't think hold on i don't think
that's fair i think you i definitely
think you you will hear new in sync on a
more con
i think you're giving too much credit in
sync because of the amount of airplay
justin timberlake still gets
i i think you might still hear bye bye
bye somewhere
the only the only nsync related songs i
hear randomly on the
radio neither of us are listening to the
radio is timberlake crimea rivers the
one i hear that pops up
i also i also
can factually say so you listen to an
80s station you're hearing the new kids
i don't know i could also i also
fashionably say that nsync
is definitely without a doubt has the
best choreography and dancing of those
of those groups too the other guys did
much more simplistic if you watch new
kids they really if you watch in sync
they really got in there you know in
sync choreography without nukes right
fairtrade all right that's it i have
more to say no it doesn't matter that's
not how this works that's time
all right good good you know how hard it
is to sing and do choreography at the
same time not a lot of people do it see
what he does he just ignores i just want
to say that i think they sang the best
and danced the best and did both of them
the best and i think that is the true
measure of a boy band respect the rules
it's over
you only hurt yourself when you break
the rules mm-hmm all right
where are we at on the clock
all right let's just go to the polls we
won't do winning tweets for these
lightning ones no people like them let's
do a little bit like two or three
they complained when we didn't do it
last time all right well we don't think
we did it for the last lightning round
all right let's just do it for you
please keep mince in their car people
put gum at the bottom of a bus seat all
right
very funny gum because you can't walk
around with mints without sounding like
you have a damn maraca in your pocket i
like both of those
uh and finally
uh listening to someone chew a mint has
never ended up with the judge change
all right that's all right that's really
funny that wins yeah uh follow at jonay
tracy joe j-o-n-n-a-y
t-r-a-c-y
uh good work
and i hope i said your name correctly
let's see who won this first round
10 000 votes too
oh man all right pippi 70 30 is big bro
that's huge that's big
all right uh we are into boxers briefs
this one is where we have boxers ride up
all the damn time while briefs stay put
and are more comfortable i'm team briefs
but i have to give it up to boxers for
hiding tiny wieners
very good all right well let's let's
yeah okay i was gonna say let's go down
a little bit because a lot of times the
algorithm will put the same people up
top yeah i got you sure as someone who's
tried both the briefs
both the briefs
as someone who's tried both
the briefs just don't give the boys
enough room to breathe the right boxes
that aren't too loose are the perfect
mix of both and keep everything in place
also i just have a feeling joe picks
briefs because he has no need to care
about ballroom
all right
to keep this podcast gender neutral
expect the next poll to be thongs versus
cheekies
all right here's our winner you smell
like jonah rose if you pick briefs is
that is that the wind
no i don't know maybe
whatever you like babe what do you like
i'm going to assume briefs is tidy white
is because he didn't put boxer briefs so
have to go with boxes
like boxer briefs or like the show
grandpa wears whitey righties because
those are mad gross all right oh [ __ ] a
lot of people are going to think it's
boxes versus boxer briefs that's fine
who cares ah that's fine
i should have put boxes versus tighties
it's okay follow it's not if i lose
briefs but briefs are brief all right
follow at five the number five ive three
zero eight
uh
good work
they are a winner for this one all right
let's see what we got here who won
nice baby nice one 60.8 boxes we're
gonna get the humble pie graphics in
here 70 30 on the government's
60.8 to 39.2
in favor of boxers
we're at a dead heat today one versus
one all right this is the biggest poll
and this is the big one folks this is
the big one
nkotb they got boy bands going if you
choose new kids on the block you must
have spent a little less god must have
spent a little less time on you and that
is a song that's lyrical song how would
you know it's gonna be may without in
sync
i love it it's gonna be me but he says
it's gonna be may okay
got it
[Laughter]
joe is going to lose because i wanted
that wait
please the winning tweet is the picture
of sal holding a gun and it just says
backstreet
that's the winning tweet that's amazing
yeah follow underscore big underscore
salad
and let's take it to the uh let's take
it to i mean instantly
oh
look i i will say though that is that
has something to do with the time that
has passed and the people voting that do
are not up on new kids on the block i i
do think they are
the the godfathers 80.4 percent humble
pie
80.4
19.6 to the new kids these were big
margin
big margin ones did we had a margin of
70 a margin of just about 70 right 70
and 270s and an 80. wow wow that might
be
this is the worst one i think is that
the is that the biggest margin error
ever
no there was one that was like 86 versus
really i think
you guys do you guys recall if there was
a bigger margin i think there was like
83 in then 80 points for 19.6
didn't something tip 80
i think you i think you should have took
backstreet there i really do that's fine
i took i went with my heart i'm not in
this game i want to know who would win
we should revisit it we should revisit
it we'll just throw it in as a uh i said
you got to go without what do you call
it what do you call it a scrimmage you
got to go with your heart it won't count
you don't be great if we get your friend
that was in in sync on the couch
how about this i i can get someone from
nuke oh i don't know oh no i wonder if i
can get an instinct and a back street in
the couch a back street yeah
yeah you know a back street well i know
people who know a backstreet including
mayan think we could definitely get an
internship i know a new kid too
let's get an n-sync and a new kid yeah
why do i got to switch to backstreet
based on your friends if you know a new
kid let's get a new kid you got a new
kid
huh it's obviously a better battle well
because well they were out of the exact
same time they were neck and neck look
you chose new kids on the block bro
and again i think that if we had this
conversation
in a more timely fashion they would be
they would be right up there but
nsync has been more relevant than them
for quite some time you had to go
backstreet and i really don't know who
would have won that that's a that's a
that's a pete that's a heater
all right well i come out two and one
today yeah
check me out uh in durham north carolina
october 29th at the deepak center
tickets are on sale right now headliner
christos stefano just no regard for the
rules that's sell volcano oh that's
right no this is this you are doing i'm
sorry you're doing it right actually you
guys didn't hold each other well i need
to see this oh my god
right now
[Laughter]
now
pip cut it in
no matter how happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you
no matter what happens i love you wait
wait wait why are you looking at me why
not i don't know because you're looking
at me no matter what happens i love you
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you oh my god
you know what it worked though the last
two episodes we didn't even shout i know
wow it was good it was healthy i think
it's you truly working we didn't get
heated
it's healthy
it's healthy wow and when it did get
heated it was like it was like
rational heated what what was last
week's battle
pool beach
no last week's
oh oh uh it was food it was uh
it was pop tarts versus english english
muffins and you won that right yeah and
i'm two and one today so in the last two
weeks with two and two yes we're really
mixing it up all right buddy
i still love you oh she still love you
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds